thanks to Best Buy for sponsoring a part
of this video they have all the gear you
need to game hello everyone I'm Alona
and welcome to my channel where today we
are playing the final installment of the
dark pictures Anthology I believe this
is called The Devil in Me and before we
go any further
um I'm having some issues with my super
ultra wide monitor it happens for like
every fifth game where the game won't
launch windowed but I'll spare you the
details basically I'm unable to see what
I'm capturing so I might accidentally
have my webcam I would text or something
like that so if that does happen
apologies
and uh
I think that's it let's do it
Lorna entertainment Charles London
please
speaking my name is Grantham demand I'm
in a privileged position
hear me out
so what do we know about this guy he's
Rich he's a recluse he's obsessed with
AJ's Holmes totally saying I'm sure
we're going to a property he inherited
from a relative some of the rooms are
full Recreations from The Murder Castle
do that has blueprints documents
artifacts when I said this would save
the show I was not exaggerating not him
I don't know how did he know what our
show was about in the first place
actually I didn't ask
Mr dumert this place is magnificent it's
amazing this is intense this is an
interesting way to open the game
cigarettes it's gonna be like
give me ten then we should get a rough
plan for getting our first shot can we
plan after dinner I want to be shooting
after dinner okay we'll be down in a few
then
Erin I checked my blue bag no cigarettes
that's where I put them come and show me
maybe one of us is colorblind
show runner I guess good luck finding
your rooms
[Music]
foreign
well I'm looking
oh Kate wanted you to have this
Kate breaking down walls navigating the
Maze of anxiety
are you [ __ ] kidding me I think she
thought it might help with your stress
absolutely not
I'm not stressed okay seems a bit
stressed do I look [ __ ] stressed
ah that was rhetorical
all your cards came out nice enough oh
yeah embossing makes a huge difference
you old guys love business cards
old school you old school guys
okay I also put it on heavy stock and
just the logo in foil
damn
I should have had one ready for Mr
dumette
did you find them I no I swear I put
them in here I don't understand Jesus
oh uh desperate
um let's do be methodical look stop
tearing around in there like a maniac be
organized about it
methodical
bag front pocket I made a specific
mental note of it
they're gone Charlie gone
just like that
are you saying somebody took them I I
don't actually I can see Kate doing that
or Jamie
I'm sorry cigarettes man
don't do it
um let's just get on with things it's
fine let's just get on with things
this place is massive surely there is a
pack of cigarettes in here somewhere
even if they're you need them that bad
there was a bar off the lobby there must
be cigarettes in the bar right I mean
technically it's not legal to smoke in
bars so come on we're checking if you
find them first all will be forgiven
see if there's anything to check out in
here
oh can I see my reflection nice 10 out
of 10 video games
all right
so um
ahh ohms of this place is I believe was
like America's first serial killer are
you worried it will make our other
episodes look cheap they are cheap it's
interesting can't be helped this will be
the one that people remember or at least
that's what it's a reference to exactly
that's the spirit he's the guy who made
this
um Hotel in Chicago we got another
season let me worry about that you stick
to making sure that my life runs
smoothly and I'll make sure you keep
working sound good supposedly fill it
with traps sure I'm trying to let them
talk
um fill it with traps and like I had
dead bodies in the walls and all that
good stuff
um but I did also see something recently
I watched a documentary about it that
implied that it maybe wasn't true so or
they couldn't oh I wanted to read that
no they couldn't verify a lot of it so
I'm not I'm not sure about it exactly
from
Grantham dumette to Joseph Morello
invitation
Mr Morello good evening thank you for
allowing me to contact you directly your
publisher said you were very keen to
hear from me it seems we have mutual
interest I spent several years
contrasting constructing the ultimate
homes tourist experience by Faithfully
recreating the World's Fair Hotel yeah
in Chicago
we have not yet opened to the public as
there are finishing touches to complete
and I consider a man of your knowledge
could provide Insight that is invaluable
before our opening official opening
therefore I invite you to visit the
hotel for the weekend the experience is
designed to accommodate groups of five
so I must extend the invitation to four
friends or family of your choosing
I would never do this I'm fine with like
a haunted house but if you have this
much space and you're using it to
torture people
and there's only five at a time that's
not even profitable you just enjoy it
which
I'm not going to trust you all right
um I must insist that this invitation be
kept confidential until the hotel is
publicly announced so please only invite
guests that you can trust to do so I
hope you can accept my invitation please
reply to confirm your attendance and the
four additional guests that you would
like to bring should you accept a
limousine will pick you up pick yourself
and your guests up at 7pm this Friday oh
so they didn't even drive themselves in
so they probably can't just go get
cigarettes
um underneath the Railway Bridge at the
corner of s Wallace Ave and West 63rd
Saint nope Street Englewood Chicago
I'm sure we'll find the experience very
interesting indeed cool can't wait to
die
sounds great
Bring It On
I'm just gonna assume there's nothing of
Interest up here
for now
hey Charlie
I was hoping next season maybe I could
do more with the sound design more
creative stuff
Erin what you already do for this
company is very valuable to us carrying
your bags and picking up your laundry
absolutely
to get ahead in this industry you have
to pay your dues so you're ready to muck
in
I
I think you should get an assistant
an assistant
oh it was just a stupid idea Charlie I'm
an assistant
a personal assistant
sort of and then I could help out with
the editing pardon me
the editing
the audience
look I just think you've got so much to
give so much experience and it's an
opportunity to pass that knowledge on
right yes I suppose it is and an
assistant wouldn't lose my cigarettes
would they nice exactly
Hotel register do you still want to
Direct One of These Charlie I am
directing
no but I mean real movies
with a big budget and big stars secret
found Erin there's something important
you have to understand in the work that
we do the very important work
truth
is the star I guess the date that we're
there I will note
um yeah sorry Charlie can you all stop
talking for a second please um
to movies can we move on from this yeah
that
just because I'm expecting everybody to
Die Here nobody to have actually left
the names for all of the people like
Brad Rachel and Jackie Scott and Grace
they wrote their own names and their own
check-in dates but the checkout dates
are all the exact same handwriting
though I guess that's not that unusual
really
with the exception of the check-in dates
for the
all the new ones they're pretty similar
looking
probably overthinking that whatever
all right
I suppose I should be thankful it's just
my cigarettes as I'm missing and not our
gear
bloody but where are my bloody
cigarettes gone you've got a bloody find
them where are they where are they
hanging
just trying to find my cigarettes mate
I don't know what accent that is hey
maybe Mr dumat is in the back office you
could just ask him about cigarettes
it's a good idea
where's the back office
out there
pretty empty
okay
find a key
I understood
that's interesting
somebody back it reception just hit that
Bell
well I guess there's no reason that the
puzzles
Murder House puzzles might have started
automatically
or immediately rather
all right
jackpot
Aaron I found the cake
cool
just because I didn't really look around
here
I did say he could use his
business card
that sounds good
I think I did that it made a noise
what does it say
welcome
you walk so slow
okay let's do it
this is interesting it does seem like
the first puzzle is already set up which
is cool
this is spooky like very fast sometimes
these games kind of take a little
a minute to get why don't I go check for
a cute shop or something I've already
had one asthma attack today and this
dust Farm is exactly what I don't need
cigarettes exactly not a girl
it is time to hear from our sponsors at
Best Buy and today I'll be showing you
the Lenovo Legion slim 7 gaming laptop
the Lenovo Legion slim 7 is a gaming
laptop powered by a ryzen processor and
Radeon graphics it's built for gaming
with Amplified performance and a premium
display the graphics are AI optimized
via the legion AI engine and it's cooled
by the legion cold front 3.0 thermal
system it's very cool Tech it's also
very light and just has such a cool
design it's made of a blend of magnesium
and aluminum and it redefines pretty
much everything I thought I knew about
laptop engineering AMD Advantage laptops
are built for Best in Class gaming with
exclusive smart performance Technologies
and premium displays so now you can
really play anywhere and on the go the
Lenovo Legion slim 7 is specifically
calibrated for next-gen creation and
gaming alike and remember Best Buy has
easy and fast fulfillment options plus
all of the latest and greatest in gaming
and Tech across PC Mobile VR and console
unfortunately
doing that
hello
the senator dummy wow
an animatronic ha that's amazing Mr de
Matt sir
they're always creepy I have a packet of
cigarettes please
a packet of cigarettes please
hello you're right Prof packet of smokes
figured it was too good to be true never
mind
thank you Robo Bowman certainly sir
whatever you wish
no [ __ ] way
thank you very much my mechanical friend
I'm already super creeped out this
happened so fast oh God okay
I guess I kind of want to explore the
rest of the room first though because I
feel like
this seems like something that will
Advance the story
I was definitely LED here regardless
right this is orchestrated for sure
you definitely wanted me to be here
[Music]
all right
um try to avoid that probably
I reckon
glasses
a bit
good morning to you all I'm Chester bell
assistant director at the Federal Bureau
of Investigation yeah
the bi at approximately zero five thirty
local time a team led by special agent
Hector Monday and supported by law
enforcement officers conducted a raid of
a motel room just outside Birmingham
Alabama to apprehend Manny Sherman The
Man known as the Beast of Arkansas
using state-of-the-art psychological
profiling techniques special agent
Monday and members of his task force not
only identified their suspect but
predicted his movement with unerring
accuracy
I'm delighted to say
we have our man
okay
not sure how that's relevant but good to
know
all right cool
his nails are so shiny dude
you got them buffed for sure
okay
um that appears to be it
cigarettes it is
Miss curly Schroeder once again I would
like to thank you for the incredible
work you and your team achieved at the
hotel
I'd like to extend my heartfelt
condolences the accident that befelled
the Skeleton Crew on the lake is nothing
short of a tragedy and I in part feel
responsible
in honor of them I have spent the last
several months applying the finishing
touches to the hotel and I'm proud to
say that we are almost ready to open to
the public
hang on
Friday November 17th
2017. I thought for some reason I
thought we were there in October but
maybe I was reading the dates
incorrectly
um
please allow me to extend my sincere
gratitude I invite yourself and the rest
of your team to join me for the grant oh
no it makes sense the weather before the
grand opening uh Grand Opening Ceremony
7 PM Friday November 17 2017. I promise
a spectacular evening with themed
entertainment including a barber shop
quartet I'm sure you will agree that all
of your hard work was worth it when you
enjoy the unique hotel experience
sincerely Richard belklap
thanks Rich appreciate you
just trying to get some cigarettes
yes
yes I can't imagine being that addicted
to anything
I guess I do really I think about coffee
a lot damn it
we only have one cup a day you know
so we need change search the bar for
money
okay hey bud hey
don't mind me
oh he moved back
zero zero two eight
oh I'm uncomfortable well what's that
I love this to interact with him maybe
well maybe I can ask him
I don't want to just steal it I'm very
worried that this
machine is going to go AWOL hey bud
could I have some cash I don't suppose
you've got any spare change back there
have you
so no
okay fine
it seems like the only option
note that I don't feel great about it
but smoking is bad anyway actually maybe
I can just like hit this or something
it's gonna happen
all right don't kill me please uh
you're right Dr Avenger
[Music]
the card
you think I'm waiting for the sound
which I just got [ __ ]
oh my God
okay yep okay yeah
yes
I love the daddy
oh
wait what does he want me to slap where
life would be so much easier hi who's
that
and much I can book it hmm
[Music]
cigarettes out of the dispenser huh
no
no please I'm having a really [ __ ] day
and you've just made it worse
that does seem unfair but to be fair I
didn't pay for it so
can we ask him now
oh yes oh
thank you Lord
oh that's supposed to indicate a camera
I think
what
oh come on you piece of [ __ ] don't do
this to me
and it's probably one of the kids give
them to me
give me my cigarettes
surely it's just gonna be one of the
kids
[Music]
I'm gonna go and get my tea grip
and they are gonna kick the [ __ ] out of
you
hey Charlie
yeah it was nobody I think it's dinner
time we should get everyone else okay
I'm coming
and I'm coming back for you where did
they go [ __ ] pry bar are you alone in
there
who's that behind the bar what
hmm thank you
very creepy
so that definitely has a camera in it
but I feel like that
makes sense
because
if you set up a house of horrors you'd
want traps you want to be able to watch
people yeah it's not weird I had a
thought on an intro segment you want to
shoot now yeah if we get it shot and in
the back maybe Charlie will stop
rewriting everything I'd come up with
yeah
okay sure it's a host Maybe
what nothing
just give me a sec and I'll be good to
go
I'm supposed to buy nothing is eating
away at you yes
how many times have you cleaned that
lens you must be I'm just precious I
guess really just prepping my gear
always focusing on the detail Mark what
about taking a huge risk and just do
something
I watched you fuss for a whole week
before you turned down that job it's a
very intense response you have to take
one extra train to get there
um cynicals I turned down that job
because that would have left you alone
with Charlie how cruel do you think I am
I'm being serious so am I fine I'll drop
it look at immature that's not immature
deflecting from somebody saying
something really intense
I don't remember
I just want to look decent
um Jamie can turn off the lights we can
get Jamie to set up some likes no I
don't want to wait around
I want to shoot something before dinner
otherwise Charlie is going to be in my
face all evening and to be honest I'm at
capacity with Jamie
I get it Mark why are you letting them
all think I broke up with you
oh I feel like if JB day the truth you
might back off I mean
they all just assumed I can't decide if
that's sweet or selfish or golf
hmm
um we're hitting the gold now let's go
we're hitting the golden hour we should
be able to find a good spot I don't know
why you camera dorks call it that
it's 15 minutes at best yes and no if
you have the right reflector 15 minutes
at the most
I've never thought about it look let's
go find some light and get started
thanks for doing this you're only asking
me because your arms are too short for a
good selfie angle my arms are not short
okay well they broke up where too like a
balcony would make for a cool angle
let's find a way up there a couple of
frame rate drops that could also be my
setup how's the new place the camera's
ready
opportunity it's just a place to keep my
[ __ ] and crash short-term lease so I can
take my time to find something really
radical I can't even see the camera's
reticle
um Smart Plan you said I needed to be
out so I got out
whoa there bucko I was just checking for
a light remember I talk about boundaries
I need my room to be my private safe
place
sometimes I'm glad we went to therapy
other times it makes for some weird-ass
rules
I don't think that's that weird I'm
worried you'd be sleeping not going in
your ex's Studio while you obsessed over
finding a perfect place with the right
wall color near the proper train station
or bus
stopwatch's bedroom it's not that way
our discussion no fly zone list
yeah you're probably right
so since we can't do it tomorrow is next
weekend okay to come and get my stuff
definitely not a balcony
there's something back here
hmm
whatever this is
definitely horror game [ __ ]
for sure
terrifying
okay
he's adding to the the dog is helping
with the horror gameplay he's adding to
the scary noises
so if to make Catches Us in here are we
breaking one of his rules
you did say not to go wandering and we
did practically bust the door down and
get him here we
so maybe we should take care
probably
they're probably cameras everywhere I
guess we're not totally alone
[ __ ]
love that great
okay yeah I feel like dumette is a kind
of dude who loses his [ __ ] if you break
his rules
when he took away our phones like we
were found in teenagers
what you doing
sticky tape
was he the devil the truth behind
America's first serial killer by Joseph
Morello
since his first book in 2002 Joseph
Morello has been fascinated by
investigating serial killers and none
have intrigued him more than H.H Holmes
in his latest paperback Morello examines
more than 15 years of his own research
and writing separating fact from fiction
to provide evidence about the truth
behind the historic case of America's
first serial killer was he the devil the
most of the Marilla fans it's like an
analysis of your worst nightmares thanks
review monthly
banjo
it's tape off him
what else have we got
this takes me back I used to carve the
hell out of my desk in Middle School
really why
a bit much
I mean this place is beautiful so far
can extend his monopod to reach high
objects okay
a bit of a weird thing to do
both deaths marriages Mr and Mrs Robert
Hall of Silver Spring announced the
birth of their daughter Marilyn on June
10 at White Oak Hospital
Elaine and Steven Wright of North Park
announced the birth of their son Maurice
on June 10 at White Oak Hospital
on behalf of their daughter Lucinda
munde proud grandparents George and
Irene Monday of Silver Spring announced
the birth of their grandson Hector
Whalen on June 11 at White Oak hospital
and it circled
my my my
chilling
a chilling Discovery Well why'd you just
take it down dude well okay
I want to put it back up but maybe you
can't
balcony
It's gotta be a way through of course
looking for another key all right
there see that key
just need to find a way through how do
you know that was the balcony key
um okay look at this wallpaper
foreign
yeah not great we'd like to avoid that
if we can
get through this this is old as hell
everything here is old as hell
I was expecting an old exterior but
remodeled inside
hmm
looks like dumette is trying to preserve
things can't be easy all the way out
here I like antiques as much as the next
person but at some point you have to
give up the ghost how much does the
average person like antiques
as much as the next person right that's
it
what essentially got here I've been
smelling something faint distant I can't
place it it's decay
dead bodies it's dead bodies for sure
it's definitely dead bodies
Island beaches with dead fish animals in
the wood could be anything whatever it
is it's dead as hell
it's dead bodies in the walls and I
really feel like I should be going up
there but wait is it flickering on can I
climb
ah I easily could have missed that okay
it's dead bodies and the Wolves it's
dead bodies and the walls
all right
it's very dark also this doesn't seem
safe
what was that
we may have just been the lamp but I
feel like it made a noise so it freaked
me out
maybe it wasn't
curious
okay this seems like a very Uncharted
puzzle
of course this will help somehow
oh
this is a very Uncharted puzzle
you gotta pull it first my guy
um however we do that
foreign
like a push mechanic like that before
hmm
can I duck
no sir oh maybe I can show up there too
ouch
you put your head down
was she behind me
you want me to go over there huh
camera
this isn't what I expected
from this room
is it ladder
right yeah
actually I'm not sure
can I climb it
back no I'm not sure what it's called
just yet for bridging it this Gap maybe
yeah that seems right okay let's do that
oh literally the path
not bad
here
but I would have thought everyone trying
to get into is this one so I'm guessing
this is gonna be locked as well yeah
okay
oh
Sparkle Sparkle hello
who are you
score
hmm
what does that do
are they good points do I want these
points
unclear
[Music]
jump and jump
I mean this place is beautiful
climb push it should work
Mark you okay in there I'll be right
back I gotta push it back to walk across
the gap
puzzles
[Music]
face this way it's a little bit awkward
to rotate but we're getting there
nice
[Music]
nice
climb
and jump and jump sorry thank you okay
it's creepy just in general
why'd you do that so slow
feels a little bit like something's
about to happen that's that's just the
energy I'm getting okay
you can do this
okay
key was here
beautiful
oh God the problem is again this is just
such a good way to die like
this
banjo you're really making it scary I
feel like going out on a balcony on a
dilapidated house that's clearly locked
up for a reason is like
you're pretty much asking to die
what good could I ever come with this
foreign
I like this new inventory system sort of
resident evily in a way
Ninja
he's chewing on a mouse box
come on it's not that high
my vertigo is saying otherwise
what you doing
what are you worried about Miss always
be camera ready
you look amazing as usual
still maintain that I think she's
the TV show
okay check this out
cool H.H Holmes
no I just this [ __ ] oh my God oh my
God
oh my God thanks Pancho thank you for
the support
a second time
Christ that got me oh my God I was not
expecting it at all
a [ __ ] up hey I'm okay
what hurts you it scares you
thanks bud hey Charlie it's eight oh my
God damn it I didn't get anything it's
still time come on let's not keep
Charlie waiting room get the crap out of
me dude oh boy okay
he's the one who chose to be on civil
blowing up on me when all I did was my
job I'm the one doing the talking on
camera not him come on you came in hot
on him and you know it not that you're
wrong but you know he meets anger with
more anger this is on him Mark not me
drama so much drama uh tired of watching
you fight the rest of us are tired of
watching you guys fight and I'm tired of
having those fights he's just jealous
jealous yeah he doesn't like that I'm
the one getting invited onto talk shows
you mean talk show
the point is I'm the one people see on
screen so they want to talk to me and
he's being a baby about it I can't say
half the shitty rights it may look good
on the page but there's more to it I'm
trying to help being a host is not that
hard as somebody who was a host for many
a year because he thinks you're just
trying to get prompted reassurance what
if I was
um that's how directors have to be
that's how directors have to be it's
their job they have a vision ego has to
play anyway a little bit
that's why I just shut up and point the
camera that doesn't mean he has to be an
[ __ ] no but imagine if you're in his
shoes
Waiting for Your Big Break Kate this
show is the closest he'll ever have to
success Tosh
I guess
it doesn't matter one way or another I
am moving on from London entertainment
hmm
good for you that's
that's definitely the right call for
where your career is going that's
sounded very sincere because it is
Charlie would replace us in a second if
he wouldn't be inconveniencing himself
he's using us I deserve better than this
so do you we all do Talent so dramatic
what a stunning performance you should
give up news and be an actress I was
quite moved by all that that's a [ __ ]
Oscar worthy you don't know what we were
talking about I heard enough thank you I
know what betrayal sounds like I'm
particularly disappointed in you mark
whatever your future plans may be right
now you work for light entertainment
and learn it information employees are
meeting for dinner to speak with our
host Charlie I'm sorry
and a lot of employees are professionals
yes so start acting like it
oh you hate to see it happy you're
always happy to see it and now I don't
that man is a goddamn child and somehow
we all sing to his level
foreign
[Music]
who rang the bell
making more animatronics
but again I feel like we do I mean it's
not weird that they have cameras that's
that's okay with me
I don't feel like it's that strange
hey guys
I think it's okay if we pour some wine
please do
poor mark
[Music]
he doesn't show up to their own dinner
party
none of you did anything to piss him off
did you no dad
I haven't seen a soul here aside from
the groundskeeper he's probably cooking
dinner himself ah Mr dumette I love what
you've done with your hair we started on
the wine hope that's all right we met
yeah that dude ain't coming wait why
you saw all the snipings you tweeted
from his limo I didn't what are you
talking about Jamie he got back aboard
the ferry and left what
wait right after we got to our rooms he
just left you're sure
you must be mistaken I'm not blind I
know what I saw why would he leave that
makes no sense
it was him as some girl they're in a big
ass hurry I saw them together when I was
looking for my room
another perfect Charles lonnet plan
comes together
what's our next step boss swim for sure
and then just leave
I'm sure he has his reasons who knows
what could have cropped up maybe he
ordered a pizza for dinner and the dock
is as far as they deliver
this could work to our advantage
well think about it we're still here
surrounded by Perfect visuals the plan
is still on track there has to be a
legit reason he left
wish and leave to conclusions
guys am I the only one who's getting
really freaked out by this place and by
Mr dumette as much as it pains me from
the depths of my soul to say it
I'm starting to side with Jamie on this
one thank you lower your voices why he's
not here
but that doesn't explain why he's dished
out on us he had to go back to establish
an alibi what are you you know so when
our bodies wash up on the other side of
the lake he has plausible deniability oh
God Jamie can you stop trying to make
this worse not healthy
what is wrong with you I'm
Charlie looks so good like his face yes
she never found your secret that's
incredible
[ __ ] of it is I did find a machine but
just like everything else in this
[ __ ] place it's ancient and broken so
what are we doing
just gonna sit here and pretend to eat
what's the plan Charlie order the pizza
the plan
in true lawn and entertainment fashion
we're going to sit with our thumbs and
our asses until a panic deadline looms
over us and then we'll just throw some
[ __ ] together and I'll save it with a
voiceover
what
wow
here's to Topeka no longer being the
worst decision Charlie has ever made
I can light them I think this is still
fine you can still shoot in there it's
just a bit weird
now I would like to toast
all of you
really
I know that I'm the butt of your jokes
and that's just my cross to bear as the
patriarch of our little family
Mark and Jamie the two of you do the
work of a team of ten
and Kate
despite our bickering
you are the heart of this show
you keep people interested
and finally to our newest recruit Erin
we would be lost without you who else
could we trust to remember every little
detail
seriously his face just hard work looks
amazing I feel like everyone else's eyes
are a little bit off but
cheers to us mazel tov
maybe it's easier to
animate with the
can take the show to the next level sure
if we have time to get it all
yeah he totally heard us
no there's no way he'd say all that nice
[ __ ] if he heard us
maybe we shouldn't talk about it right
this second I agree you brought it up
what was that Kate nothing important
just spitballing some ideas I think
she'll look best if we can really make
the backgrounds look as creepy as
possible shouldn't be hard
um does anyone else think it's weird do
Matt hasn't showed up yet yeah I don't
think he's coming
what do we want to do first Charles
you're the boss thank you
I think it makes sense for us to start
in the lobby there's still decent light
to work with and it's simple that was a
weird conversation they just had in the
Murder Castle
we just need to set up a couple of Our
Own
we can make it look as if it were lit by
Gaslight perfect
what if dumette shows up
if he tells us to stop I'm going to be
having a strong word with them he's put
us in this position
all right everyone grab what they need
and we'll make beside it like are just a
strange choice or the wine please
no mistakes
perfection
if he comes back I don't want him to see
us [ __ ] about or arguing Google we're
on it right guys fantastic I'd love to
hear that
shouldn't take me long at all
right
great
[Music]
there's something in that wine
surely
okay
okay oh that's Charlie
electronic Charlie cool
[Music]
hello
guys
is that you
foreign
like different abilities based on their
based on their roles oh this is super
creepy
thank you
[Music]
oh my God
Charlie
[Music]
wait that's where it's coming from so
what am I supposed to do about it
oh am I supposed to like press RT on it
maybe
[Music]
again it's definitely where it's coming
from
that's where he threw it
Professor JP Hunter is an author and
council with over 20 years of experience
helping patients overcome their anxiety
and panic attacks within this book you
will find a step-by-step guide designed
to give you the tools you need to find a
puff out of the maze of anxiety
following a unique monthly plan you will
learn anxiety busting tips and tricks to
incorporate into your daily
into your busy daily life
Professor JP Hunter has helped thousands
of people manage their anxieties and
given them the confidence they need to
break down walls and Tackle their demons
face on
cool
oh okay
reading techniques for emergencies this
is interesting
in earlier chapters we looked at how
abdominal breathing
can help build resilience against
anxiety practicing techniques such as
tummo or pranayama pranayama for just 20
minutes a day has been shown to build a
buffer against stress over time but
sometimes when the sudden anxiety or
panic attack sudden you need quicker
techniques for the moment this is what
we'll be exploring in this chapter
the five for five technique deep breath
in deep breath out that makes sense find
a seat that's comfortable as comfortable
as possible and loosen any restrictive
clothing breathe in gently through your
nose for five seconds try breathe into
your stomach but don't worry if you
can't
breathe out through your mouth for five
seconds as if you're uploading out a
candle
repeat this for five minutes until you
begin to feel comma note
some people find it helpful to picture a
relaxing environment whilst they breathe
I like to imagine floating through space
not weird why that or just put your
headphones on
so again we know it's here
but what about it
okay I can't get in
this is still just someone yeah I mean
okay so some other way to get in through
there
maybe there's a different sound to
follow
foreign
this could be really spooky this as a
mechanic
that's an art
[Music]
is okay
that's gonna be a yikes from me dog
yeah I think this is the only way to go
again I don't know if there's some other
way for me to
interact with this door
it's this one for sure
what do you want me to do about it x a b
I'm going to do not know
any way to interact
not that I can see
um
[Music]
I really do think that's just Charlie
crying so we're just gonna keep moving
well on that note it does look like I've
been playing for about an hour so I'm
going to leave it there
this is awesome so far it's like extra
spooky from the jump like I said which I
love
um and I'm sure I will play more of this
game whether I stream it or play it on
uh YouTube I'm not sure about yet I'll
probably stream it I'm still trying to
catch up on Shadows of Rose first but
I'll be getting to that this week I
haven't been streaming much lately thank
you for watching huge thanks to Bandai
Namco for sending me a code so that I
could play the game early I love these
super massive games I think they're so
much fun that is it for me today
everybody I will see you guys next time
bye thanks to Best Buy for sponsoring a
part of this video shop the links in my
description